times are
dark a violent struggle for power draws
nearer but the chaos of the revolution
is the perfect cover for an
assassin the Phantom Blade is no
ordinary weapon it is an instrument of
stealth that in the right hands will
unleash Terror in the hearts of those
who would seek to stop you concealed
under your sleeve it remains
unnoticed until it is time to
strike a hidden blade will cut down
those who stand in your
way IR retractable crossbow shoots a
dart with great Precision to surprise
your
enemies when the time comes an assassin
must be swift cunning and show no
mercy
a skilled assassin will unlock the
secrets of the Phantom Blade and use his
weapon to rise amongst the greatest
heroes of
battle now you can wear the Assassin's
Phantom
Blade get the Phantom Blade and receive
a code to unlock the exclusive French
Cavalry pistol in Assassin's Creed Unity
it's your turn to make
history